Yeah,
the inward,
the short answer is that my could not
stand the inward,
had no use for it in the context of its
use,
did not matter to her.
Her thing was very simply that if I have
a vial,
a with a cross bones and skulls on it
and the word p o l I s o n written on
the bottle.
It's poisoned.
If I take that same poison and pour it
into the most beautiful vase of baccarat
crystal ever made,
it's still a poison for her.
The context of the use of the word and
didn't matter.
Now this was a generational thing
because my was 30 some years older than
I am a or was at the time of us having
this conversation and my view of the
inward has a bit more nuanced.
A,
again,
based upon the generation that I've been
raised in and the music that I listened
to in the culture that I've been a part
of.
So my view is a little bit more liberal
than my view on the inward.
And so we had this debate for years
about whether or not,
you know,
the inward was something that ought to
be used in any context.
And we never agreed on that.
There are a number of things we never
agreed on.
She asked me when I was in Africa,
what I thought the greatest virtue was
of all the virtues tab is,
which is the greatest virtue for you.
And I said,
I think love is the greatest of all the
virtues.
And she said,
uh,
I think courage.
I said,
really?
She said,
yeah.
So for 28 years of our friendship we
debated,
which is the greatest virtue,
love or courage.
Her argument was that it takes courage
to love it.
My argument was,
but,
but love is courage enacted a,
I believe that love is the greatest of
all the virtue.
She thought it was courage and we never,
we never settled that debate.
So there are a number of things that we
would come back to time and time again
over the course of our relationship.
And we had different opinions.
The point of this is that she allowed me
to interrogate her.
She allowed me to disagree.
She welcomed my opinion.
She wanted to hear what I thought on a
particular issue,
even if she thought I was wrong.
We had debates about the merits of art
versus entertainment and what makes
something art,
what makes something entertainment.
So we had these debates all the time,
but it was.
It was such a beautiful relationship
where we were always allowed to engage
each other and no matter what the
conversation was,
no matter how tense or terse it might've
been about a particular subject matter.
Every conversation always,
always,
always ended on a love note.
She never allowed the conversation to
end without it being on a low note.